guten abend nach berlin diana kinder
guten abend herr kleber was haben sie so
gedacht als sie ihre vorsitzende gestern
abend haben reden hören ich war
zumindest irritiert über die wortwahl
finde dass sie nicht eindeutig
juristisch pressefreiheit und
meinungsfreiheit angegriffen hat und von
der juristischen regulierung gesprochen
hat finde aber zumindest irritierend
dass in einer wahlanalyse dieses thema
so prominent auftaucht und hätte mir
lieber im demütigen
demuths vollem worte gewünscht in
richtung eigenem versagen was wäre dann
das versagen dass sie ernennen würden
wenn sie sie gefragt hätte ich weiß
natürlich dass die cdu sich im
zufriedenstellt mit den zwei wahlzielen
stärkste kraft geworden zu sein und
bremen zurückerobert zu haben und sehe
aber ein ausfransen der politischen
mitte beide volksparteien haben enorm
verloren und gleichzeitig wird die
jugend gerade von den bürgerlichen von
der bürgerlich liberalen volkspartei gar
nicht mehr angefasst
man sieht ja in den statistiken das
erstmal ganz massiv die unter
30-jährigen weder cdu noch spd wählen
sondern überwiegend die grünen aber das
geht hoch bis zu den unter 60 jährigen
haben sie ein rezept dagegen
ich habe natürlich nicht dass eine
rezept ich kann mir verschiedene
versäumnisse denken
ich glaube man muss ein bisschen die
große koalition in schutz nehmen wir
haben ein wahlergebnis bekommen bei der
bundestagswahl bei der wir versucht
haben eine jamaika koalition zu zu
gründen das hat nicht funktioniert dann
mussten zwei großkoalitionäre in
verantwortung treten und haben eine
unangenehme lösung aufgefunden die sie
aber verantwortungsbewusst zeigt und da
geht das eigene profil natürlich ein
bisschen verloren und gleichzeitig werfe
ich der großen koalition natürlich im
vor dass die zukunfts lust ein bisschen
abhandengekommen ist
nun haben sie ja durchaus einen
wichtigen stellen gearbeitet innerhalb
der union mit dem vorsatz sie jünger
dynamischer netz als fina und so weiter
zu machen und erleben dann das jetzt die
reaktion wieder so hilflos sind das zum
beispiel auch der parlamentarische
staatssekretär im wirtschaftsministerium
so von oben herab ihn per twitter welt
liebe jugend werte doch endlich mal
vernünftig wie wir offensichtlich bringt
ihre botschaft nicht durch ich bin ein
mitglied von 500.000 mitgliedern da
versuche ich mich mit meinen themen und
meinen positionierung in richtung mitte
geltend zu machen
ich glaube dass wir gesellschafts
liberaler werden müssen ich glaube dass
wir innovativer werden müssen
ich glaube dass wir uns nicht mit links
rechts debatten ablenken sollen
überlebten ideologie streit inszenieren
soll leitkultur fragen stellen soll die
fand globalen problemlösung ablenken
sondern gerade die jugend erwartet im
pragmatische nüchterne liberale
problemlösung und das scheint nicht
durchzukommen
das sind ja erst mal alles schlagworte
liberale problemlösung klingt zb gut was
wäre das war im konkreten ausdrücken
naja ich glaube dass vor allem dinge die
grünen profitieren von von einer
verheißung die sie im prinzip in
regierungsverantwortung nie richtig
durchsetzen mussten
ich glaube dass die realen klimaeffekte
von plastik verboten in großstädten oder
einem diesel fahrverbot in innenstädten
relativ gering ist und glaube dass
wirkliche klimaschutzpolitik eben global
funktioniert das hat etwas zu tun mit
digitaler infrastruktur und
kapitalbeschaffung für grüne startups
das hatte was so etwas damit zu tun wie
handelsabkommen klug ausdifferenziert
sind damit wir bei logistischen wegen
sparen
und ich glaube dass es auch extrem etwas
mit einer klugen außenpolitik zu tun hat
und mit einer sehr effektiven
entwicklungshilfepolitik weil da die
großen fresser von co2 sitzen wenn man
das problem aber dann von deutschland
oder von der eigenen umgebung hoch
schiebt auf die große welt bühne dann
ist das auch immer eine technik um ein
problem und seine lösung auf den sankt
nimmerleinstag zu verschieben
ich glaube es ist das gegenteil ich
glaube wir dürfen uns gerade eben nicht
auf eine populistische art und weise
einlassen dass deutschland mit
nationalistischen scheinlösung die
eventuell sogar sozial unverträglich
sind wie bei einer ganz einfachen co2 am
steuer
wo gerade sozial schlecht gestellte
familien quasi irgendwie leiden weil es
zum beispiel heizung benzinkosten teurer
werden ich glaube dass man diese lösung
and tan muss und schauen muss wie kann
man wirklich durch innovationskraft
durch eine zukunfts lust im startup
bereich durch nachhaltiges bauen durch
mobilität strategien durch green city
solutions bei den städten nachhaltiger
gebaut sind wie kann man über solche
ebenen die bevölkerung an nachhaltigkeit
heranführen
und sie eigentlich ein laden statt
moralisch ihnen etwas aufzuziehen nun
sind das alles wieder forderungen und
mich wirklich lösungen wahren dringt die
union plus die spd zurzeit bei jungen
leuten wie ihnen nicht durch naja ich
glaube dass wir gewachsene volksparteien
haben die sich eben es lange zeit auf
diesem links rechts auf dieser links
rechts achse verortet haben und ich weiß
es von mir selber dass ich mich da gar
nicht so richtig wiedererkennen kann und
weiß es von vielen leuten aus meiner
generation dass sie nüchtern sind das
die gesellschafts libera sind dass sie
nach lösungen suchen und da ist das denn
egal ob die fdp mit den grünen an
technologischen innovationen arbeiten
oder die cdu mit der spd weiter
bildungspolitik macht sie wollen
ergebnisse sehen nach vorne gerichtet
sind
die sich nicht nur um einlösen von etwas
defizitären aus der gegenwart kümmern
sondern wirklich im präventiv
katastrophen in zukunft verhindern und
gleichzeitig auch mit nummer denn das
hätte ihn nach vorne zukunft eben
möglich machen und wie optimistisch sind
sie aus ihrer perspektive dass bis 2021
dem geplanten wahltermin die union in
dieser hinsicht ganz anders darstellt
als heute
naja der ganz generelle trend geht eben
in die richtung dass sich vor allem die
jungen die junge generation nicht in den
parteien engagiert und das empfinde ich
ein großes fiasko weil ich immer noch
daran glaube dass parteien im
der wichtigste das wichtigste vehikel im
parlamentarismus sind und ich wünsche
mir in erster linie dass die parteien
ihre strukturen aufbrechen und junge
leute zur mitarbeit einladen
dadurch müssen die kampagnen fähiger
sein sie müssen themenspezifischer sein
sie müssen digitaler sein und sie müssen
eben jungen leuten und im leuten aus
zielgruppen die unterrepräsentiert sind
bei ihnen zu lassen dass sie einen punkt
setzen können und zwar auf sachebene
dass man sie nicht von oben herab
beschwichtigt und dann glaube ich kann
eine junge generation auf augenhöhe die
eigene lebenswirklichkeit die eigenen
bedürfnisse und die eigenen interessen
auch einsetzen dankeschön
vielen dank